okay [ __ ] we are [ __ ] back okay
let me just [ __ ] say this game we're
gonna kill this jellyfish [ __ ] I have
been [ __ ] fighting this guy for a
while and I [ __ ] to spell that out of
ammo this is cap so that's what I'm
gonna do where's that [ __ ] where's that
that you wanna [ __ ] my get nut yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] back I kept that [ __ ]
the captain oh [ __ ] okay looks like a
job here is done
holy [ __ ] that was crazy
they're dying here
now of course Michael a [ __ ] him up - I
[ __ ] them all up okay
I [ __ ] them all up please is he here
okay okay
[ __ ] hack that [ __ ] I mean I'm so
[ __ ] mad
I have been trying to [ __ ] get
pathology for awhile I think the whole
entire last episode is me [ __ ] with
it
excuse holidays and okay
prosecutor1 left to determine okay all
right that okay [ __ ] like I doing here
huh and I think I kill the eel monster
from here right
look at this [ __ ] yes yes yes
that's an y'all glue gun put the
injector in there
did I get his body out my dad may have a
parallel section
[ __ ] I like nothing
No [ __ ]
where do they [ __ ] go okay how great
you are
[ __ ] okay send you
all right Felix we're finally getting
[ __ ] done okay I got my coffee oh and I
know a lot of people are like
psychobabble like I've been watching it
for awhile and I'm going to consent buy
your coffee drink it but yeah [ __ ] ya
betch hey said ya know second water I
[ __ ] did that I could did that okay
complete
you see what this [ __ ] has how do you
see what I can do here I have a second
one this come on [ __ ] make them look at
HSN that was [ __ ] terrible this is
like the worst part look again
and I can take that with my body cat
okay go the Power Plate holy [ __ ] that
was bad it makes me so angry
it just makes me so angry you know like
I try my bells are you know why do I to
fight that jellyfish monster with our
rats for a network okay let's say what's
waiting for me I need to reactor much
you're always locked away in your
workshop but I can talk you through your
bracelet to guide you for you okay that
subjective you can okay let me help her
out
okay L'Aquila [ __ ] is that
I can throw [ __ ] like any yeah I can
sort of chair
Oh [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
but crusher thing whatever the [ __ ] it
is
where is it
security station what is that a book Hey
how can I hate that [ __ ] okay well
anyway I got a hack that's okay because
that's what hack it does you just
[ __ ] carry it oh [ __ ] Oh
oh good thank ya thank you
wait I download it
I guess an engineer control krill
engineering operator stop stiffen up
sailing along [ __ ] like nice holy
[ __ ]
anything else here get sick [ __ ] you
look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate that
[ __ ]
sub operations engineer okay
[ __ ] you know there's some little talk
dude in there [ __ ] egg okay
oh shut you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it off
you know in the head yes it up [ __ ]
right right right
we charge a charge [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right that's [ __ ] what is that a
camera
he repaired three
this firefights supposed to cancer okay
I'm gonna say can I go in here
Americans feel discouraged
looking for me yeah what's the story on
Mikayla's office I filed an incident
report I'm sure it's a page-turner but I
don't have time I need to get a crew on
the other side of that breach so what's
the problem problem is blacker than my
butthole at the bottom of a well in
there that's s surrounding resistor
malfunctioned swapped the new one and
you should have your lights as well all
right you still rattled what's up
I tried replacing the resistor yesterday
dude and it just melted into some kind
of goo I like fried ass [ __ ] that's not
no report is it I need to get some sleep
my shifts over anyway maybe you'll have
better luck come on
okay we shoot that thing first I guess I
need to get some sleep
my shifts over anyway maybe you'll have
better luck
ah ah now
vital signs critical you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] we need to get
some sleep
my shifts over anyway maybe I'll have
better luck
is this a resister
oh yeah ow [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] -
there they go
Hey okay
come on come on
what's up [ __ ] this one's [ __ ] suck
dick I can't [ __ ] see [ __ ] okay
no no no no
[Music]
[Music]
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
how the [ __ ]
now out out out
okay get it from here come on come on
that's come on no now now now come on
[ __ ] come on [ __ ] okay worry Ellen
bring backup
thank God okay I did oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
No get me up there again [ __ ] up
there right here this is a spot a [ __ ]
are you come on I know you're in here
come on oh yeah
okay here we go this is what I'm talking
about
what is that what is that oh [ __ ] na
[ __ ] I hear second yeah yeah my Bella
[Music]
quick save okay
[Applause]
there we go
what is that wet noise where are you Ben
can I go
where are you better I got you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay now what am I doing
here just gonna access coach part
storage change last shift
we had a short so security clean up and
reset oh sure thank you hey maybe it's
not my place but what spit it out well
it's just that there was a minor leak
and I told Connolly we should wait for
new parts but Duncan I don't give a [ __ ]
about your pissing contest with Connolly
tickets Brooks code is embedded in this
message code is embedded in that message
[ __ ] where's pasilla font
set I cannot [ __ ] I gotta go back so
with that whole [ __ ] thing is
pointless I just said
okay anything was [ __ ] pointless
weird all right
[ __ ] [ __ ]
tap down [ __ ] going on there
haha
okay um um I got buckets sure because it
so comfortable right there
okay good good okay Holly [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I see you okay [ __ ]
but holy [ __ ]
okay Jason okay well I gets upstairs
first
jesus [ __ ] mimicked all in there
I'll get the turns drive any kits my
chance now the Apple desk I can't eat
that can I nah this is [ __ ] disgusting
someone stairs I got clean there shut up
okay this X is online okay - this place
is huge man
okay that's right you'll be locked out
okay Morgan you'll need is supervisor
keycard Thalia Brooks in the coolant
room she did not make it but she'll
probably have a card on her eye which is
in the corn room that shall place
okay good I think up there oh [ __ ] so
annoying I don't care why you can hack
things that are like finer in ink
see like the blood flow the [ __ ] game
alright I going to react time room okay
all right let's go over there let's
going on here
[Music]
like that mm-hmm okay we're going this
way guys
man this turn is [ __ ] oh sorry about
that
hey seven oh [ __ ] please scanning target
your type of material
Oh Oh [ __ ] shut these guys up you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
still [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] watch
like 20 Anna she says okay here's the
plan
[ __ ] put this on here oh is that okay
I'm glad that's one up here skyrocket
your type of material now passenger
version 0.76 quicksave hey Kevin 3/5
alright picture
[ __ ]
okay now we need the rest of them okay
[ __ ]
[ __ ] run out here this is disgusting
where thing yeah maybe not
can I pop this guy [ __ ]
okay we sit here and see here
you're the [ __ ] here scanning your
alien material [ __ ] okay okay okay
[ __ ] is this right
I can shake aunt ro it's up there hands
okay that's fine
[Music]
okay China the paralytic [ __ ] - [ __ ]
going on I found today my first as had
you put your put your [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was four modernizations [ __ ] is up
there where I like a [ __ ] hour
answer control room let me see I'm on
the power plant right area down okay so
I get I got he's going up I think
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I'll pay me enough to
do this [ __ ] that's for sure this looks
that whale sound and I'll see your
[ __ ] whale hmm [ __ ]
come on the storage room it was not [ __ ]
there though got to go up half crowning
sister I'm going to go back in put that
in there and say
and I will said do you have the crazy
things idea for a lot you know
get cool chambers below so Santa [ __ ]
I get in their last scene fucking-a okay
their body here I have not yet found
what the [ __ ]
where's that cigarettes [ __ ] that I
throw that hard
maybe it's at downstairs time yeah
because there's nothing down there
then I thought I found his
but it sucks today thank you should have
this as backup just in case
okay kind of awkward
what did nothing do upstairs sound like
a computer now is in the path line
already
okay Connolly
holy [ __ ] this gay pop don't [ __ ]
worry that's crazy guys their body
around here the engineering offices holy
[ __ ] the glass [ __ ] now my level
what the [ __ ] is that okay okay thank
God I still somewhere this this is weird
what the [ __ ]
okay I'm like insanely perplexed as to
what I'm supposed to do to breach cannot
get beyond that point how is your cert
array okay we check them out
security station there did that makes
that computer still good
not a word [ __ ] here anyway access is
already complete
Talya Brooks
here we go huh what the [ __ ] she's like
in the fire
she can just reach in there okay no no
burn tell me you plan to make in an
unconventional manner a few weeks ago
yeah was it a mass kissing bird named
crass the COFF maybe care to elaborate
not if I'm going to get my peepee
slapped worse oh don't you in the eel
tank ouch now supply was out apart so I
borrowed a clue gun from the guys
hardware worked out okay next time let's
make sure you have enough spare parts to
do the job right Roger that boss boys
you Mike Morgan who's talking to me ah
system alert repair is needed please
contact a qualified engineer I thought I
was going to die well sooner than I
thought I was going to die
we ended up being come from does it told
me the way it was looking at me I get up
except for my legs and my lungs my
nervous system won't look surprised
powerful exes remember you want me the
boosters are in my office
no way I'm getting there now but at
least I was serious before I think we
can bypass the lockdown
okay the reactor control room there's a
panel for shutting down everything the
whole station the computer will scream
of you but just do it then playing it'll
come back when you cycle the power it
should hit will no go what happened here
should appear not sure is our period
sure okay now there are a lot of things
to go do now
holy [ __ ] it's a timer you don't
remember her but she remembers you she
hid her condition to work abort tell us
one when you found out she should have
been sent back to earth but you made an
exception I'm not sure if that makes you
responsible sista alert beeps you won't
last long without medication a qualified
engineer it's up to you if you want to
help her
I gotta do it that fair bit what his
[ __ ] it's part of your brother's
lockdown the main lift and every
exterior airlock you're stuck until you
can do something like he's trying to
looking down Morgan and putting everyone
at risk in the process I can't [ __ ]
go out there [ __ ] [ __ ]
how much time do I add two hours all
right now if I had to get local I had to
get that holy [ __ ]
that scared date [ __ ] out of me thank
you diagnosing superficial injuries is
nothing a portable minimum this won't
take long
there's that scares the [ __ ] out of a
questionnaire at the front desk [ __ ] you
[ __ ] too scared now oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] day to get the door date
to get into dark
well maybe I can ask
oh yes he'll maybe that's diagnosing
cruising operations 51 again hold still
this is common this was our talk about
to close would come with my
questionnaire your feedback will be
invaluable yes yes me too
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I could be there's like
struggling Mouse ok mantains left center
left
No
[ __ ] my computer's like yeah like
where's iCal my hey
and just make sure I'm not missing
anything in his office on that side [ __ ]
I can't tell
hmm
[ __ ] weird
okay there was the box here this
man it is [ __ ] choppy in here let me
tell you my frame rate is going down
just under that [ __ ] no mods chiller
is that another office down there I
can't tell
get closer
okay okay
[Music]
and looking holy [ __ ] baby yeah
that's on their nests wait let me just
find out what I'm supposed to do or a
vote it
[ __ ] it
[Music]
[Music]
okay yes yes yes - [ __ ] nose [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] engage in the correct order
the [ __ ] was you order I don't read that
okay okay mag [ __ ] is everything on
there now for stop okay
mag sub photo okay mag tap stop photo
[Music]
right initiating reactor shutdown
sequence substation power grid offline
photovoltaic rings off life support
Oh a cat one reactant successfully shut
down initiating main reactor ignition
sequence in three two my name is fear
warning Briana initialization
interrupted roaring Godzilla report
check those addresses a week ago all
right Morgan going down to fix it
yourself or find a replacement it's
without luck I don't know what I'm doing
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] why they
make me a charge of this morning
how the [ __ ] like how do I get in there
okay okay here's another way in no of
course not
I'll flag and Claire's note the
governor's in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh shut okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] anything in here I can
actually use oh [ __ ] why are there so
many of these things not good
this is not [ __ ] good
oh okay I got let me just get a couple
of these bad boys because that's [ __ ]
nose I'll made it come on come on come
on you could do a boy Mikayla is
counting on us [ __ ] you know
power any other than I try to [ __ ]
again just one more just reward
combat
okay you got that run for your [ __ ]
life ah ah ah oh [ __ ] it
yeah okay what's up [ __ ] do I do can i
[ __ ] heal it now do I please be eight
yes yes okay okay where is it
[ __ ] I just threw it somewhere okay good
good good
you me get the [ __ ] out of here where's
the anti-red out out out
okay okay okay was it resembling house
reactor initialization complete systems
restored I'm showing power to the lift
Amir walks but seeing a lot of power
spike the cooling chamber watch yourself
on the way back there could be a
distraction look damaged [ __ ]
well I see you said everything
tell us one is wide open now clever
reckless clever we get the [ __ ] out of
here how do I get out of here I'm not
gonna get in your way anymore come up to
my office
ah ah yeah whatever you need I felt it
in my gut
if this is some kind of payback powers
coming back online
what the [ __ ] who makes these their
system
[ __ ] [ __ ] now
how do I get out of here okay okay okay
I can take it huh huh [ __ ] let me thank
here for one second let me just [ __ ] up
to here for one second okay don't get to
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] jellyfish thing
[ __ ] hate this [ __ ] oh okay okay
a suit suit suit suit suit okay yellow
[ __ ] [ __ ] running
she's kissing love shame on you
typically she with me okay everything is
fine everything is [ __ ] spy
okay that's my sign this okay they
really need okay [ __ ]
yes yeah no no no no - open up low okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
final shot that can't quick little
[ __ ] the clothes okay I just I am
exactly where I was ten minutes ago only
Kanine krunchies in here can eat forgot
the fastest way to get the [ __ ] outta
here Tony [ __ ] super P what's that
what am I doing here
you [ __ ] [ __ ] so [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] where is it
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] where's that the
flying [ __ ]
stretch marks very posh three parts okay
okay I can't breathe for like a hot
second do I have okay save [ __ ] I think
over there
like jump
yeah [ __ ] I can like that I can make it
now I can you up here you up here
I can you can come up I'm up here oh
[ __ ] okay okay okay come on Jesse bah ah
what the [ __ ] what vital signs critical
where is it where is it took anything oh
[ __ ]
okay okay calm down
[ __ ] a the guys like a [ __ ] machine
gun which I are going to go wow I could
go higher I can go higher
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right all right please
stop shooting at me
[ __ ] where am i we're okay
oh [ __ ] now now
careful Morgan gasps alarm went off in
the coolant chamber after you powered
reactor backup welcome the turbine
hydrogen cool now they're leaking you
take a shot and it's your night it will
be like shooting as remuneration
secretly it would are you feeling better
soon okay all better you can fill out a
service crutch that's all a warning I
need oh my god that's been crazy we're
going to get organs yet okay well it's
an hour so we'll do in an episode okay
adios adios